when machine gets consciousness
it's called
singularity
from hand Bumble yeah I got banned from
them for Life For Life well it says that
you're banned for life wait that's not
how they say it is this a your you know
your um subscription is um
but then I try to redo it and they're
like no you're terminated so the only
way to do it is I have a plan wait wait
a second simultaneously hinge and Bumble
on the same day said no more
yeah
but why did they tell you why yeah
people complain they're not the same
company I know it's just ironic that
happened the same day I think it's
because uh well I lie
I think it looks up a lie to win I'm a
liar to win it no I because I I lie
about my age
and I don't think I should do that but
you know it's funny I I but it did it
was the reason you and I matched because
I didn't put my age past uh 40
I think 40
two yeah or something like that and you
were just right under like 41 yeah yeah
you gotta lie but my point is that you
have to lie on that you've got to do it
but on but on the actual like profile
thing I say in parentheses I'm 51.
oh that's fine
a yellow lie yeah a yellow light and and
I think according to
um this one Korean show that's called a
pink lie it's a pink lie yeah yeah and
so um maybe you ask why I do that why do
you do that because
um
I have a theory the theory is this it's
like Korean years is like dog years
right there's white ears right so I'm 51
white years but I'm 35 Korean
biologically biologically I look I look
younger than 51. wait we should have Dr
David Sinclair here because he talks
about your chronological years versus
what you're like biological years are
yeah yeah what you're like your years on
paper versus how your body reads yeah so
you identify as a what age man a 35 year
old man that's why I identify it I can
attest to this whatever Andrew Santino's
ages that's what I identify he's 40
right yeah in any lineup right you put
me in Andrew if you guys didn't know who
we were same age
or even maybe he's older on many poles
you know what I mean maybe right it did
always concern me that like for myself I
always wanted to be with someone older
so that I would always be the young
hussy yeah and as the years passed I was
starting to mature and you just kind of
stayed the same so that was really
concerning for me but also secondly I'd
like to say that I can attest to the
fact that not just biologically but even
behaviorally you're closer to being 12
than you are 50. thank you what what
that was uh that's not good that's not a
good thing it sounded good but it didn't
feel right it didn't feel right yeah
maybe older no but you are close to
being like
you're a man baby oh man baby so I kind
of put 15. yeah so yeah so I got that's
a bummer and then um and then Raya you
can get banned there no but I get it's
nothing Dead Zone Dead Zone and now I'm
not even looking any woman that comes up
I just do it
why don't you try men
no there are guys let's try to sneak up
on my thing and they're cute huh no
you're telling me that Hollywood gays
are not cute that's a lot it's they're
no it's not it's not the guys that like
me it's like when I go on to the um you
know when you can slide left and right
yeah every once in a while you see a guy
like Frank you know I mean who's trying
to slide in because Frank wants to go
out with a straight guy yeah who's not
gay but he can turn him oh really that's
what Frank is the passion of feeling
yeah and I've always sometimes you know
thought maybe Frank right I want to see
what his game is and how strong it is
but you know um yeah so I'm bummed about
it but it is but Raya is just they don't
you know they don't like me did you
choose the name Frank like Frank hot
dogs
like Frank's what's a Franklin like uh
how they call it a Frank also there's
other people there are people white
named pranks also that's the first name
I think you made hot dogs but
um yeah well I don't know what you're
trying to do but I was just like great
Association this is smart that's clever
but
um yeah I'm picky but you know I'm it's
fine I'm just gonna have to I mean I
have a plan
don't tell them because then they're
going to be on to your plan what this
video will be submitted clipped out and
sent to Bumble corporate even if I share
my plan how are they going to figure
that out okay because I'm gonna lie this
next time okay so this is my next game
Korean state if I can get back on Bumble
and hinge yeah yeah my next game is I'm
just gonna say my name
I'm just gonna say my age I mean
like the way you're supposed to do it
yeah I mean my name was Vladimir before
yeah he was a Frank yeah I was Frank
Vladimir Frank Gonzalez was my name but
no I'm gonna do my real age and I'm just
gonna just go you know what
you know what because I could still
swipe on people it's just people aren't
going to be able to see my because I'm
51. what happens is if you say you're 51
the girls that are on these dating sites
are all in their late 40s and 50s so
they all look like Judy denge you know I
mean you know
[Laughter]
kind of sort of your age range like why
is that such a terrible thing for you
what's because you just want to play
around no no no no no no no that's not
no no that's not it that's not it it's
just that um I have an idea we should
try to let him answer I mean my dad was
my dad was 15 years older than my mom
oh wow no okay your your dad was 45
years older yeah and he that was
predatory
so if I did a 35 year old that's
predatory no
but I think that hasn't you guys are now
changing the age of that too
no we're all going to prison baby
I'm in jail yeah I mean how old is your
how old are you three she's three years
younger than me and how old are you 33
you're that young yeah happy
um marriage I went to your wedding and
also thank you both for being thank you
for the gift but thank you both